by this game if you want a reason to
yourself
garbage pros cheap cons visually
unappealing horribly optimized
unskipable cutscenesthat's playing this
horrendous game this is a home screen
not bad so far I guess we're doing
single-player yeah
take note it says it's in beta so it
might be nothing or maybe it's just
saying the game is a beta game so it
kind of looks like GTA oh look at me I
feel weird for playing this I'm gonna be
honest it's actually kind of moving on
the way wait are these people he'll
punch something boom oh wait I can't
punch yet so far I don't see why people
hated this looks kind of cool put a
mini-map there Bofur got to make it work
in case you're wondering this game costs
$10 okay so we're gonna try to see if
it's worth it oh wait gangstas oh oh
yeah well you have a good press e I bet
it's a no F none - none
all right here hold up always find the
key input no dad why there's no controls
there are controls we just don't know
all right I'm gonna match every button
on the keyboard hope my first person in
speed these these views yes
eh I go to those cars and punctual in
the windows swim that's all you have
take it back hey thank you oh my gosh
hello I picked up his ammo come here
wait the copy just went away after that
no way just this look at how I look
running
how you doing there hey can I have your
phone number no Jimmy's getting a
Minecraft girlfriend
oh gosh pops the car get it that's a cop
nothing here nothing to see here please
do not open the door Chrissy
nothing yo he's shooting in the
civilians how could he I'm in a oh look
at the flick on this man
oh I'm tapping out who has to take over
this maze in the barbershop go get a
haircut I don't have any money no just
robbed a barbershop
look at the lighting obviously there was
a lot of potential here I don't know why
they gave up on the game they hadn't
have given up on it could have been good
oh look if we had some money we could
have got armor thanks for wasting our
money Jimmy for driving soon as women to
a shot on me you can't find there's
gotta be five pics lot well how are you
supposed to get wondering first go to
the business center but I can't hold
anybody for ransom without you oh just
pull up they might give you a job and
starting to see it why they're reviews
for how they where we're gonna reload
you get our gun back because I feel like
we're supposed to have our guns oh wait
okay here we have a job okay I want you
to rob don't road work is not difficult
moreover I will provide you with weapons
and a car isn't it cool I just came here
and intend to engage in illegal business
yes don't worry you already have
experience in this manner after all you
need starting capital I will help you
with this okay what is our plan here
bandanna the gun and the keys to this
car I hate this so much
the store will still be safe it can be
opened with a drill take this bag in it
the whole instrument you'll have to do
with the guard at the door the new point
the gun at the cellar he gives you the
all the cash next to him we'll be safe
we'll be safe
all right Brian and what about the cops
let's hope that you had time to leave
before their arrival I'll agree I'll
pick you up at 23 23 is not a time light
into the vehicle all right
oh no I'm gonna do what I do best in G
yeah you don't even get stars for that
wait Chris go go back through double tap
make sure you know you actually killed
them what am I supposed to go just look
at the mini-map oh wait it doesn't work
here there's a robbery right there
whatever I alright look it's by the
hospital wait so that's gotta be the
hospital right there the big red
building oh why are people out so late
no they're doing their thing set this
gun that was your car come on Craig Lee
oh wait guys I've got to go eat olive
coordinate with my life well maybe you
shouldn't be fleeing cars off ramps I
want you to robe store alright I got the
gun I'm getting in the car all right
right here so we're looking for this
right here the beauties kids all right
start your shot right there
yeah yeah dude I'm a genius oh there it
is there get a tool hold up park your
car park it dude this is a getaway spot
let's see if Chandler can finally
complete the mission weekend I got
security camera shot take money from
cash box so put that fool down yeah yeah
yeah listen this store doesn't work what
shoot in the air yo come on wait where's
the drill it's doing it Rob very
successful okay grab that money right
there got that okay weights drilling
Chrissy on that oh wait wait it's still
drilling right wait you go back in there
disables yeah it wasn't safe did it
there was only 52 bucks in the safe then
Brian said jerk oh alright returned
Brian I'm not gonna lie that was me go
steal the car first get the dub from the
mission dawg once I do one crab I like
to just keep doing cry oh oh that
pedestrian knew he was turning she did
sorry you there were so much lady in
cutscene what's going on y'all I'm just
passing wishing we're up top four and a
half grand boys nice dude it looks like
the three members of Big Time wage Oh
get the white card get the white card
yes we could have a brand new mission we
wouldn't even know because we couldn't
read a word he said where should we go
next
good so done so all right all right all
right gun store to lose robber begins
wait wait wait wait I want to see if
he's in there still what if he
recognizes me
hi welcome to the store yeah hands up
guys yeah the drill I'll be here before
robbery success robbery they just leave
if you just why do you put it down so
you know I'm gonna get the best gun in
the edges oh wait where's your white
card good wait what did you spawn why oh
yeah there is here it is gunshot gunshot
gunshot gunshot yeah we've got to fight
somebody Chris got their friend against
your [ __ ] why are you robbing a good
store yeah SWAT teams on the way brother
you got three stars for a defender with
your life
why does the gas they should have more
money than the gun store well those
people keep getting killed though you
just lose your stars when you walk
outside well the robbery was complete
hey there's your car is that my car wait
car is grim ran ran ran ran ran ran for
him oh yeah
yes stuck stuck whoa boy go over top and
look down you're not even touching a
steering wheel all right you're gonna
have to get a different car just go to
the bank this is it
no this apartment let's see what them
jumps cost three hundred thousand quit I
hope that means quit playing because
that's crazy now what's up with this
freaking place Murr get up pick up his
ammo pick up as a my boys where's the
main for this hundred fifty dollars no
really boy when I bribe 250 I get in
trouble oh here's my car I'll shoot the
window shoot the window I did that and I
got in trouble
no judge this is actually not that bad
like this would be a cool like sandbox
world to play winces oh there's a third
cop Oh Chandler if you're a true gamer
you can kill all five let's go back to
the gun store get more weaponry
let's give off a fighting chance all
right boys guns store I think right yeah
cars got hiccups rap rap rap Angra
anybody in here yeah because you blew it
up we can't buy more guns to rob the
bank because we killed the guns later if
I try it with a pistol and I die the gun
store will respawn and then Carl can
give it a chance so you only have six
bullets nah John he's just gonna kill
one person gets a man yeah yeah he gets
Jan Jan
ya know this about to be the most live
bank robbery of our generation you so
shoot those people first should know
shoot these yeah yeah yeah oh my god
nothing oh my gosh this is so bad
see how much am i none jump back there
quick go hang out with those guys see if
you can take their guns
alright so reload I think on what
happens you look all you have to do is
just not rob the guns hey it's almost
like we hope you got money go to the gun
sir orange will shoot the window I don't
have a gun oh wait oh we get in the car
the white cars back over there that's
gotta be yours nobody else parks like
this yeah oh by that by that so we gotta
get this rig in that just look at the
stunt why does this one have Q speed
it's a speed at the top it's read at the
bottom double speed speedy boy
[Applause]
that was so much better than all of us
make everything cooler you don't even
rob the bank just keep driving towards
the sunset no just keep going towards it
it looks too good all right Carl when
you walk in if you go into the staff
only room they will shoot all right you
got to be strategic
you could probably line all the cops up
yes so you got a little bit of cover
Carl face stop running towards more
people to tilt yeah they're not even
hitting you dude you're like invincible
right now you don't have my eyes on you
though go to the tool place go get a
drill and then come back and rob the
bank
everyone in the bank just oh my god Carl
one mob or the cops on you takes a lot
by both by like seven should we revisit
the gun store get work and for what
why'd you get pork stars for buying that
guys we need a hold hands this is the
big moment
Carl hold of oh no you got walk-in
cooler editor play a soundtrack
[Music]
oh there's no one in here I'm ready to
be money oh they just opened it wait I'm
good my graphic II II D what's what
C oh I'm so good at this game oh my god
ro we got a 31 grave we can buy a
business now business face of my command
car and that was the worst game we could
find on Steam it was enjoyable
I wouldn't recommend you buy it because
it probably would have been miserable if
you're alone anyone else this throat
hurts from screaming I'll be sucking on
it weenies like you do